la parole est à madame le ministre de la
santé monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les députés
si j'interviens aujourd'hui à cette
tribune ministre de la santé femmes et
non parlementaires ont proposé aux élus
de la nation une profonde modification
de la législation sur l'avortement
croyez bien que c'est avec un profond
sentiment d'humilité devant la
difficulté du problème comme devant
l'ampleur des résonances qu'il suscite
au plus intime de chacun des françaises
et des français est en pleine conscience
de la gravité des responsabilités que
nous allons assumer ensemble mais c'est
aussi avec la plus grande conviction que
je défendrai un projet longuement
réfléchi et libéré par l'ensemble du
gouvernement
un projet qui selon les termes mêmes du
président de la république a pour objet
de mettre fin à une situation de
désordre et d'injustice et d'apporter
une solution mesurer et humaine un des
problèmes les plus difficiles de notre
temps si le gouvernement peut
aujourd'hui vous présenter un tel projet
c'est grâce à tous ceux d'entre vous et
ils sont nombreux et de tous horizons
qui depuis plusieurs années se sont
efforcés de proposer une nouvelle
législation mieux adapté au consensus
social et la situation de fait que
connaît notre pays c'est aussi parce que
le gouvernement de monsieur messmer
avait pris la responsabilité de vous
soumettre un projet novateur et
courageux chacun d'entre nous garde en
mémoire la très remarquable et émouvante
présentation qu'on avait
est monsieur jean taittinger c'est enfin
parce que au sein d'une commission
spéciale présidée par monsieur bergé
nombreux sont les députés qui ont
entendu pendant de longues heures les
représentants de toutes les familles
d'esprit ainsi que les principales
personnalités compétentes en la matière
pourtant d'aucuns s'interrogent encore
une nouvelle loi est elle vraiment
nécessaire pour quelques-uns les choses
sont simples il existe une loi
répressive
il n'y a qu'à l'appliquer d'autres se
demandent pourquoi le parlement devrait
trancher maintenant ces problèmes nul
n'ignore que depuis l'origine et
particulièrement depuis le début du
siècle la loi a toujours été rigoureuse
mais qu'elle n'a été que peu appliquée
en quoi les choses ont-elles donc changé
qui oblige à intervenir
pourquoi ne pas maintenir le principe et
continuer à l'appliquer catherine
exceptionnel
pourquoi consacrer une pratique
délictueuse et ainsi risquer de
l'encourager pourquoi légiférer et
couvrir ainsi le laxisme de notre
société
favoriser les égoïsmes individuels au
lieu de faire revivre une morale de
civisme et de rigueur pourquoi risquer
d'aggraver un mouvement de dénatalité
dangereusement amorcé au lieu de
promouvoir une politique familiale
généreuse et constructive qui permettent
à toutes les mères de mettre au monde et
d'élever les enfants qu'elles ont
construit parce que tous nous montre que
la question ne se pose pas en ces termes
croyez vous que ce gouvernement est
celui qui l'a précédé
ce serait résolu à élaborer un texte à
vous le proposer s'il avait pensé qu'une
autre solution était encore possible
nous sommes arrivés à un point où en ce
domaine
les pouvoirs publics ne peuvent plus
éluder leurs responsabilités tout le
démontre
les études et les travaux menés depuis
plusieurs années les auditions de votre
commission
l'expérience des autres pays européens
et la plupart d'entre vous le sentent
qu'ils savent qu'on ne peut empêcher les
avortements clandestins et qu'on ne peut
non plus appliqué la loi pénale à toutes
les femmes qui seraient passibles de ces
rigueur pourquoi donc ne pas continuer à
fermer les yeux parce que la situation
actuelle est mauvaise je dirais même
qu'elle est déplorable et dramatique
elle est mauvaise parce que la loi est
ouvertement bafoués pire même ridiculisé
lorsque l'écart entre les infractions
commises et celles qui sont poursuivies
est telle qu'il n'ya plus à proprement
parler de répression
c'est le respect des citoyens pour la
loi et tongs l'autorité de l'état qui
sont mis en cause
lorsque des médecins dans leur cabinet
enfreignent la loi et le font connaître
publiquement
lorsque les parquets avant de poursuivre
sont invités en référé dans chaque cas
au ministère de la justice
lorsque les services sociaux
d'organismes publics pour nice tu as des
femmes en détresse les renseignements
susceptibles de faciliter une
interruption de grossesse lorsque aux
mêmes fins sont organisés ouvertement et
même par schachter des voyages à
l'étranger
alors je dis que nous sommes dans une
situation de désordre et l'anarchie qui
ne peut plus continuer
[Applaudissements]
mais me direz-vous pourquoi avoir laissé
la situation se dégrader ainsi et
pourquoi la tolérer pourquoi ne pas
faire respecter la loi
parce que si des médecins si des
personnels sociaux
si même un certain nombre de citoyens
participent à ces actions illégales
c'est bien qu'ils s'y sentent contraints
en opposition parfois avec leurs
convictions personnelles
ils se trouvent confrontés à des
situations de fait qu'ils ne peuvent pas
connaître
parce qu'en face d'une femme décidée à
interrompre sa grossesse
ils savent qu'en refusant leurs conseils
et leur soutien
il la rejette dans la solitude et la
angoisses d'un acte perpétré dans les
pires conditions qui risquent de la
laisser mutilés à jamais ils savent que
la même femme
s'il a de l'argent si elle sait
s'informer se rendra dans un pays voisin
ou même en france dans certaines
cliniques et pourra sans eau courir
aucun risque ni aucune pénalité mettre
fin à sa grossesse et ces femmes ce ne
sont pas nécessairement les plus immoral
mais plus inconsciente
elles sont trois cent mille chaque année
ce sont celles que nous côtoyons chaque
jour et dont nous ignorons la plupart du
temps la détresse et le drame
c'est à ce désordre qu'il faut mettre
fin
c'est cette injustice qu'il convient de
faire cesser mais comment y parvenir
je le dis avec toute ma conviction
l'avortement doit rester l'exception
l'ultime recours pour des situations
sans issue
mais comment le tolérer son qu'il perd
son caractère d'exception sans que la
société paraissent l'encourager je
voudrais tout d'abord vous faire
partager une conviction de femmes
je m'excuse de le faire devant cette
assemblée presque exclusivement composée
d'hommes aucune femme ne recourt de
gaieté de coeur à l'avortement
il suffit d'écouter les femmes
c'est toujours un drame c'est toujours
un drame
cela restera toujours un drame c'est
pourquoi si le projet qui vous est
présenté tient compte de la situation de
fait existantes
s'il admet la possibilité d'une
interruption de grossesse c'est pour la
contrôler et autant que possible en
dissuader la femme
nous pensons ainsi répondre au désir
conscient ou inconscient de toutes les
femmes qui se trouvent dans cette
situation d angoisse si bien décrite est
analysé par certaines des personnalités
de votre commission spéciale a entendu
au cours de l'automne 1973 actuellement
celles qui se trouvent dans cette
situation de détresse qui s'en préoccupe
la loi les rejette non seulement dans le
propre la honte et la solitude mais
aussi dans l'anonymat et l'angoissé
poursuite contrainte de cacher leur
étant trop souvent elle ne trouve
personne pour les écouter les éclairer
et leur apporter un appui et une
protection
parmi ceux qui combattent aujourd'hui
une éventuelle modification de la loi
répressive
combien sont ils ceux qui se sont
préoccupés d'aider ces femmes dans leur
détresse
combien sont ils ceux qui au delà de ce
qu'ils jugent comme une faute ont su
manifester aux jeunes mères célibataires
la compréhension et l'appui moral dont
elle avait un si grand besoin
[Applaudissements]
je sais qu'il en existe et je me
garderai de généraliser je n'ignore pas
l'action de ce qui profondément
conscients de leurs responsabilités font
tout ce qui est à leur portée pour
permettre à ces femmes d'assumer leur
maternité nous aideront leurs
entreprises
nous ferons appel à eux pour nous aider
à assurer les consultations sociales
prévues par la loi
mais la sollicitude et l'aide
lorsqu'elles existent ne suffisent pas
toujours à dissuader
certes les difficultés auxquelles sont
confrontées les femmes sont parfois
moins grave qu'elle ne les perçoivent
certaines peuvent être dédramatiser
surmonter mais d'autres demeures qui
font que certaines femmes se sentent
acculés à une situation sans autre issue
que le suicide la ruine de leur
équilibre familial ou le malheur de
leurs enfants
c'est là hélas la plus fréquente des
réalités ya davantage que l'avortement
dit de convenance
s'il n'en était pas ainsi croyez vous
que tous les pays les uns après les
autres auraient été conduits à réformer
la législation en la matière et à
admettre que ce qui était hier
sévèrement réprimée soit désormais légal
ainsi conscients d'une situation
intolérable pour l'état et injuste aux
yeux de la plupart
le gouvernement a renoncé à la voile la
passivité celle qui aurait consisté à ne
pas intervenir suite hélas le laziale
laxisme assumant ses responsabilités il
vous soumet un projet d' un projet de
loi propre à apporter à ce problème une
solution à la fois réalistes humaine est
juste
certains penseront sans doute que notre
seule préoccupation a été l'intérêt de
la femme que c'est un texte qui a été
élaboré dans cette seule perspective il
n'y est guère question ni de la société
ou plutôt de la nation ni de peur de
l'enfant à naître et moins encore de cet
enfant je me garde bien de croire qu'il
s'agit d'une affaire individuelle ne
concernant que la femme et que la nation
n'est pas en cause ce problème là
concerne au premier chef mais sous des
angles différents et qui ne requiert pas
nécessairement les mêmes solutions
l'intérêt de la nation
c'est assurément que la france soit
jeune que sa population soit en pleine
croissance
un tel projet adopté après une loi
libéralisant la contraception ne
risque-t-il pas d'entraîner une chute
importante de notre taux de natalité qui
amorce déjà une baisse inquiétante
ce n'est là ni un fait nouveau
nine évolution propre à la france un
mouvement de baisse assez régulier des
taux de natalité de fécondité est
apparue depuis 1965 dans tous les pays
européens
quelle que soit leur situation en
matière d'avortement ou même de
contraception il serait hasardeux de
chercher des coups simples un phénomène
aussi général aucune explication ne peut
être apportée au niveau national il
s'agit d'un fait civilisation révélateur
de l'époque nous vivons et qui obéit à
des règles complexes que d'ailleurs nous
connaissons mal les observations faites
dans de nombreux pays étrangers par les
démographes ne permettent pas de dire
s'il est qu'il existe une corrélation
démontré entre une modification de la
législation de l'avortement et
l'évolution des taux de natalité et
surtout de fécondité
il est vrai que l'exemple de la roumanie
semble démentir cette constatation
puisque la décision prise par le
gouvernement de ce pays à la fin de
l'année 1966 de revenir sur des
dispositions non répressive
depuis dix ans plus tôt a été suivie
d'une forte explosion de natalité
cependant ce qu'on omet de préciser
c'est qu'une baisse non moins
spectaculaire s'est produite ensuite il
est essentiel de remarquer que dans ce
pays on n'existait aucune forme de
contraception moderne l'avortement a été
le mode principal de limitation des
naissances
l'intervention brutale d'une législation
restrictive explique bien dans ce
contexte un phénomène qui demeurait
exceptionnel et passagers tout laisse à
penser que l'adoption du projet de loi
n'aura que peu d'effet sur le niveau de
la natalité en france les avortements
légaux
remplaçants en fait les avortements
clandestins une fois passée une période
d'éventuels oscillations à court terme
il n'en reste pas moins que la base
notre natalité si elle est indépendant
de l'état de la législation sur
l'avortement est un phénomène inquiétant
à l'égard duquel pouvoirs publics ont
l'impérieux devoir de réagir
une des premières réunions du conseil de
planification co-présidera le président
de la république va être consacré un
examen d'ensemble des problème de la
démographie française et des moyens de
mettre un frein à une évolution
inquiétante pour l'avenir du pays
quant à la politique familiale
le gouvernement a estimé qu'il
s'agissait d'un problème distinct de
celui la législation sur l'avortement et
qu'il n'y avait pas lieu de lier ces
deux problèmes dans les discussions
législatives ce qui ne signifie pas
qu'il n'y ait pas qu'il n'ya pas qu'ils
attachent paul une extrême importance
dès vendredi
l'assemblée aura délibéré d'un projet de
loi qui améliore très sensiblement les
allocations servi en matière de frais de
garde et les allocations dit d'orphelins
qui sont notamment destinés aux enfants
des mères célibataires ce texte réforme
en outre le régime de l'allocation
maternité et les conditions
d'attribution des prêts aux jeunes
ménages
en ce qui me concerne je m'apprête à
proposer à l'assemblée divers projets
l'un d'entre eux tend à favoriser
l'action des travailleuses familiales en
prévoyant leur intervention éventuelle
au titre de l' art social
un autre projet améliorera les
conditions de fonctionnement et de
financement les centres maternels où
sont accueillis les jeunes mères en
difficulté pendant leur grossesse et les
premiers mois de la vie de leurs enfants
j'ai l'intention de faire un effort
particulier pour la lutte contre la
stérilité par la suppression du dic au
modérateur pour toutes les consultations
à cette matière et j'ai également
demandé à l'inserm de lancer dès 1975
une action thématiques de recherche sur
ce problème de stérilité qui désespèrent
tant de coupes avec monsieur le garde
des sceaux je me prépare à tirer les
conclusions du rapport que votre
collègue monsieur rivière s partout le
manthey en mission vient de rédiger sur
l'adoption
répondant au voeu de tant de personnes
qui souhaitent adopter un enfant
j'ai décidé d'instituer un conseil
supérieur de l'adoption qui sera chargé
de soumettre aux pouvoirs publics tout
suggestions utiles sur ce problème
enfin et surtout le gouvernement s'est
publiquement engagé par la voix de
monsieur durafour a entamé dès les
toutes prochaines semaines avec les
organisations familiales la négociation
d'un contrat de progrès dont le contenu
sera arrêtée d'un commun accord avec les
représentants des familles sur la base
de propositions qui seront soumises au
conseil consultatif de la famille que je
préside
[Applaudissements]
en réalité comme le soulignent tous les
dix mots draps ce qui importe c'est de
modifier l'image que se font les
français du nombre dit idéal d'enfants
par couple
cet objectif est infiniment complexe et
la dissuasion de l'avortement ne saurait
se limiter à des mesures financières
nécessairement ponctuelles
le second absent dans ce dans ce projet
aux beaucoup d'entre vous sans doute
c'est le père la décision de
l'interruption de grossesse ne
devrait-il pas comme chacun leur sang
est reprise par la femme seule mais
aussi par son mari ou son compagnon
je souhaite pour ma part que dans les
faits il en soit toujours ainsi et
j'approuve votre commission de nous
avoir proposé une modification en ce
sens mais comme elle l'a fort bien
compris il n'est pas possible d'un situé
en cette matière une obligation
juridique
enfin le troisième absent
n'est ce pas cette promesse de vie que
porte en elle la femme
je me refuse à entrer dans les
discussions scientifiques et
philosophiques dont les auditions de
votre commission ont montré qu'elle
posait un problème insoluble lui
personne ne conteste maintenant que sur
un plan strictement médical l'embryon
portant lui définitivement toutes les
virtualités de l'être humain qu'il
deviendra
mais il n'est encore qu'à devenir qui
aura surmonté bien des aléas avant de
venir à terme un fragile chaînon de la
transmission de la vie faut-il rappeler
que selon les études de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé sur 100 conception
45 s'interrompent d'elle-même au cours
des deux premières semaines et que sur
100 recettes au début de la troisième
semaine
un quart n'arrive pas à terme du seul
fait de phénomènes naturels
la seule certitude sur laquelle nous
puissions nous appuyer
c'est le fait que la femme ne prend
pleine conscience qu'elle porte un être
vivant qui sera un jour son enfant que
lorsqu elles ressentent en elle les
premières manifestations de cette vie et
c'est sauf pour les femmes tu animes une
profonde conviction religieuse
ce décalage entre ce qui n'est qu'un
devenir pour lequel la femme n'éprouve
pas encore de sentiments profonds et ce
quel enfant
dès l'instant de sa naissance qui
explique que certaines qui repousserait
avec horreur l'éventualité monstrueuse
de l'infanticide se résigne à envisager
la perspective de l'avortement
combien parmi nous devant le cas d'un
être cher dont l'avenir serait immédiate
doublement qu'on irrémédiablement
compromis n'ont pas eu le sentiment que
les principes devait parfois céder le
pas il n'en serait pas de même
c'est évident si cette taxe est
véritablement conçu comme un crime comme
un autre certains parmi ceux qui sont
les plus opposés au vote de ce projet
accepte qu'en fait on n'exerce plus de
poursuites et s'opposeraient même avec
moins de vigueur au vote d'un texte qui
se bornerait à prévoir la suspension des
poursuites pénales
c'est donc que mêmes perçoivent qu'il
s'agit là d'un acte d'une nature
particulière ou en tout cas d'un acte
qui appelle une solution spécifique
l'assemblée ne m'en voudra pas d'avoir
abordé largement longuement cette
question vous sentez tout ce que c'est
là un point essentiel sans doute le fond
même du débat il convenait de l'évoquer
avant d'obtenir à l'examen du contenu
même du projet en préparant le projet
qu'il vous soumets aujourd'hui le
gouvernement s'est fixé un triple
objectif faire une loi réellement
applicable
faire une loi dissuasive faire une loi
protectrice
ce triple objectif explique l'économie
du projet tout d'abord une loi
applicable
un examen rigoureux des modalités et des
conséquences de la définition de cas
dans lequel seraient autorisés
l'interruption de grossesse révèle
d'insurmontable contradictions
si les conditions sont définis en termes
précis par exemple l'existence de graves
menaces pour la santé physique ou
mentale de la femme par exemple les cas
de viol ou d'inceste vérifié par un
magistrat il est clair que la
modification de la législation
n'atteindrait pas son but
si ces critères sont réellement
respectée puisque la proportion des
interruptions de grossesse ayant de tels
motifs est faible au surplus
l'appréciation des cas éventuels de viol
ou d'inceste soulèverait des problèmes
de preuves
pratiquement insoluble dans un délai
adaptée à la situation si au contraire
c'est une définition large qui est
donnée par exemple le risque pour la
santé psychique où les équilibres
psychologie ou encore la difficulté et
les conditions matérielles et morales
d'existence
il est clair que les médecins ou les
commissions qui serait chargé de décider
si ces commissions si ces conditions
sont réunies aurez à prendre leurs
décisions sur la base de critères
insuffisamment précis pour être objectif
dans de tels systèmes
l'autorisation de pratiquer
l'interruption de grossesse n'étant
pratique donné qu'en fonction des
conceptions personnelles des médecins ou
des commissions vis-à-vis de
l'avortement
et ce sont les femmes les moins habiles
à trouver le médecin le plus
compréhensif ou la commission la plus
indulgente se trouvera encore dans une
situation sans issue
pour éviter cette injustice
l'autorisation est d'ailleurs donnée
dans le cas des pays de façon quasi
automatique ce qui rend une telle
procédure inutile tout en laissant à m
tout en laissant aux femmes un certain
nombre de femmes qui ne veulent pas d'un
coup et l'humiliation de se présenter
devant une instance qu'elles ressentent
comme un tribunal
or si le législateur est appelé à
modifier les textes en vigueur
c'est pour mettre fin aux avortements
clandestins qui sont le plus souvent le
fait de celle qui pour des raisons
sociales économiques ou psychologiques
se sortent dans un telle situation de
détresse qu'elles sont décidés à mettre
fin à leur grossesse dans n'importe
quelles conditions
c'est pourquoi renonçant une formule
plus ou moins ambiguë plus ou moins
vagues
le gouvernement a estimé préférable
d'affronter la réalité est de
reconnaître qu'en définitive la décision
ultime ne peut être prise que par la
femme remettre la décision à la femme
n'est ce pas contradictoire avec
l'objectif de dissuasion le second de ce
que tu assassines ce projet ce n'est pas
un paradoxe que de soutenir qu'une femme
sur laquelle pèse l'entière
responsabilité de son geste hésitera
davantage à l'accomplir que celles qui
auraient le sentiment que la décision a
été prise à ta place par d'autres le
gouvernement a choisi une solution
marquant clairement la responsabilité de
la femme parce qu'elle est plus
dissuasive au fond qu'une autorisation
émanant d'un tiers qui ne seraient ne
deviendrait vite qu'un faux semblants ce
qu'il faut c'est que cette
responsabilité
la femme ne l'exercent pas dans la
solitude ou dans l' angoisse tout invite
tout en évitant d'instituer une
procédure qui puisse la détourner d'y
avoir recours
le projet les bois dont diverses
consultations qui doivent la conduire à
mesurer toute la gravité la décision
qu'elle se propose de prendre le médecin
peut jouer ici un rôle capital
d'une part on enferme encontre en
informant complètement la fin des
risques médicaux de l'interruption de
grossesse qui sont maintenant bien connu
et tout spécialement de risques de
prématurité de ses enfants futurs et
d'autre part en la sensibilisant aux
problèmes de la contraception
cette tâche de dissuasion et de conseil
revient au corps médical de façon
privilégiée et je sais pouvoir compter
sur l'expérience et le sens de l'humain
des médecins il s'est fort d'établir au
cours de ce colloque singulier le
dialogue confiant et attentif que les
femmes recherchent parfois même
inconsciemment le projet prévoit ensuite
une consultation auprès d'un organisme
social qui aura pour mission d'écouter
la femme
le couple lorsqu'il y en a un peu lui
laisser exprimer sa détresse de l'aider
à obtenir des aides cette détresse
financière de lui faire prendre
conscience de la réalité des obstacles
s'opposent ou semble s'opposer à
l'accueil d'un enfant tient les femmes
apprendront ainsi l occasion cette
consultation qu'elle peut accoucher
anonymement et gratuitement à l'hôpital
et que l'adoption éventuelle de leur
enfant peut constituer une solution
il va sans dire que nous souhaitons que
ces consultations soient les plus
diversifié possible et que notamment des
organismes qui se sont spécialisés pour
aider les jeunes femmes en difficultés
puissent continuer à les accueillir et
leur apporter l'aide qui les incite à
renoncer à leur projet
tous ces entretiens auront naturellement
lieu seul à seul
il est bien évident que l'expérience et
la psychologie des personnes appelées à
accueillir les femmes en détresse ont
contribué de façon non négligeable alors
apporté un soutien de nature à les faire
changer d'avis ce sera en outre une
nouvelle occasion d'évoquer avec la
femme le problème de la contraception et
la nécessité dans l'avenir d'utiliser
des moyens contraceptifs
on ne plus jamais avoir à prendre la
décision d'interrompre une grossesse
pour les cas où la femme désirait pas
avoir d'enfant
cette information en matière de
régulation des naissances qui est la
meilleure dissuasion l'avortement vous
paraissiez essentielle que nous avons
prévu d'en faire une obligation sous
peine de fermeture administrative à la
charge et atic établissement où se
ferait les interruptions de grossesse
les deux entretiens que le rat us ainsi
que le délai de réflexion de huit jours
qui lui sera imposée est paru
indispensable pour faire prendre
conscience à la femme de ce qu'il ne
s'agit pas d'un acte normal banal mais
d'une décision grave qui ne peut être
prise sans donne à voir peser les
conséquences et qu'il convient d'éviter
à tout prix
ce n'est qu'après cette prise de
conscience et dans le cas où la femme
n'aurait pas renoncer à sa décision
que l'interruption de grossesse pourrait
avoir lieu cette intervention ne doit
toutefois pas être pratiqué sans de
strictes garanties médicales pour la
femme elle même et c'est là le troisième
objectif du projet de loi
protéger la femme tout d'abord
l'interruption de grossesse ne peut être
que précoce
parce que ces risques physiques et
psychiques ils ne sont jamais nulle
deviennent trop sérieux après la fin la
10e semaine qui suit la conception pour
que l'on permette aux femmes de s'y
exposer ensuite l'interruption de
grossesse ne peut être pratiqué que par
un médecin
comme c'est la règle dans tous les pays
qui ont modifié leur législation dans ce
domaine mais il va de soi qu aucun
médecin ni aucun auxiliaire médical ne
sera jamais tenu d'y participer
enfin pour donner plus de sécurité à la
femme l'intervention ne sera permise
qu'en milieu hospitalier public ou privé
il ne faut pas dissimuler que le respect
de ces dispositions que le gouvernement
juge essentiel et qui reste sanctionné
par les pénalités prévues à l'article
317 du code pénal maintenu en vigueur à
cet égard implique une sérieuse remise
en ordre que le gouvernement entend
mener à bien
il sera mis fin à des pratiques qui ont
reçu récemment une fâcheuse publicité et
tu ne pourront plus être toléré dès lors
que les femmes ont la possibilité de
courir ligue de recourir légalement à
les interventions accompli dans de
réelles conditions de sécurité de même
le gouvernement est décidé à appliquer
fermement les dispositions nouvelles qui
remplaceront celles de la loi 10 920 en
matière de propagande de publicité
contrairement à ce qui est dit ici ou là
le projet n'interdit pas de donner des
informations sur la loi sur la loi et
sur l'avortement
ils interdits l'incitation à
l'avortement par quelques moyens que ce
soit car cette incitation reste
inadmissible
cette fermeté
le gouvernement l'a montrera encore en
ne permettant pas que l'interruption de
grossesse donne lieu à des profits
choquant les honoraires et les frais
d'hospitalisation ne devront pas
dépasser des plafonds fixés par décision
administrative
en vertu de la législation relative aux
prix dans le même souci
et pour éviter de tomber dans les abus
constatés dans certains pays
les étrangères devront justifier de
conditions de résidence pour que leur
grossesse puissent être interrompus
je voudrais enfin expliqué l'option
prise par le gouvernement qui a été
critiquée par certains sur le non
remboursement de l'interruption de
grossesse par la sécurité sociale
lorsque l'on sait que les soins
dentaires les vaccinations obligatoires
les verres correcteurs ne sont pas ou
sont encore très incomplète mans
remboursés par la sécurité sociale
comment faire comprendre l'interruption
de grossesse soit elle rembourser si
l'on s'en tient si l'on s'en tient aux
principes généraux de la sécurité
sociale l'interruption de grossesse
lorsqu'elle n'est pas thérapeutique n'a
pas à être prise en charge
faut-il faire exception à ce principe
nous ne le pensons pas car il nous a
paru nécessaire de souligner la gravité
d'un acte qui doit rester exceptionnel
même s'il entraîne dans certains cas une
charge financière pour les femmes ce
qu'il faut c'est que l'absence de
ressources ne puisse pas empêché une
femme de demander une interruption de
grossesse lorsque vraiment cela
s'avérerait indispensable c'est pourquoi
l'aide médicale a été prévu pour les
plus démunis
ce qu'il faut aussi c'est bien marquer
la différence entre la case
contraception qui doute qui lorsque les
femmes ne désire pas un enfant doit être
encouragée par tous les moyens et dont
le remboursement par la sécurité sociale
vient d'être décidée et l'avortement que
la société tolère
mais qu'elle ne saurait ni prendre en
charge ni encouragée rares sont les
femmes qui ne désirent pas d'enfant la
maternité fait partie de
l'accomplissement de leur vie et celles
qui n'ont pas connu ce bonheur en
souffre profondément
si l'enfant une fois n'est rarement
rejetés et donna sa mère avec son
premier sourire les plus grandes joies
qu'elle puisse connaître certaines
femmes se sentent incapables en raison
des difficultés très grave qu'il
connaisse un moment de leur existence
d'apporter un enfant l'équilibré
affectif et la sollicitude qu'elle lui
doit à ce moment elles feront tout pour
l'éviter ou ne pas le garder et personne
ne pourra les en empêcher mais les mêmes
fins quelques mois plus tard leur vie
affective matériel étant transformé
seront les premières à souhaiter un
enfant et deviendront peut-être les
maires les plus attentives
c'est pour celle là que nous voulons
mettre fin à l'avortement clandestin
auquel elle ne manquerait pas de
recourir au risque de rester stérile ou
atteinte au plus profond d'elle-même
j'en arrive au terme de mon exposé
volontairement j'ai préféré m'expliquer
sur la priorité général du projet plutôt
que sur le détail de ces dispositions
que nous examinerons à loisir au cours
de la discussion des articles
je sais qu'un certain nombre de tours ou
estimeront en conscience qu'ils ne
peuvent voter ce texte
pas davantage qu'aucune loi faisant
sortir l'avortement de l'interdît et du
clandestin cela j'espère les avoir au
moins convaincu que ce projet est le
fruit d'une réflexion honnête et
approfondie sur tous les aspects du
problème est que si le gouvernement a
pris la responsabilité de le soumettre
au parlement
ce n'est qu'après en avoir mesuré la
portée immédiate aussi bien que les
conséquences futures pour la nation je
n'en donnerai qu'une preuve s'excusant
d'une procédure tout à fait exceptionnel
en matière législative
yves le gouvernement vous propose d'en
limiter l'application à cinq années
ainsi dans l'hypothèse où il
apparaîtrait de cours de ce laps de
temps que la loi que vous auriez voter
ne seraient plus adaptées à l'évolution
démographique au progrès médical
le parlement aurait à se prononcer à
nouveau dans cinq ans en tenant compte
de ces nouvelles données
d'autres hésitent encore ils sont
conscients de la détresse de trop de
femmes et souhaite leur venir en aide
ils craignent toutefois les effets les
conséquences de la loi à ceux ci je veux
dire que si la loi est générale et donc
abstraite elle est fait pour s'appliquer
à des situations individuelles souvent
angoissantes que si elle interdit plus
elle ne crée aucun droit à l'avortement
et que comme le disait montesquieu la
nature des lois humaines et d'être
soumise à tous les accidents qui
arrivent et de varier à mesure que les
volontés des hommes chance au contraire
la nature des lois de la religion et de
ne pariez jamais les lois humaines
statue sur le bien la religion sur le
meilleur c'est bien dans cet esprit que
depuis une dizaine d'années grâce au
président de votre commission des lois
avec lequel j'ai eu l'honneur de
collaborer lorsqu'il était garde des
sceaux a été rajeuni être dé transformer
notre prestigieux code civil
certains en train alors qu'en prenant
acte d'une belle image la famille on ne
contribuent à la détériorer il n'en a
rien été et notre pays peut s'honorer
d'une législation civile désormais plus
juste plus humaine mieux adapté à la
société dans laquelle nous dit-on par
nature inconnue
[Applaudissements]
m
je sais que le problème dont nous
débattons aujourd'hui concernent des
questions un piment plus grave et qui
trouble beaucoup plus la conscience de
chacun mes dents définitives
il s'agit aussi d'un problème de société
je voudrais enfin vous dire ceci au
cours de la discussion
je défendrai ce texte au nom du
gouvernement sans arrière-pensée et avec
toute ma conviction mais il est vrai que
personne ne peut éprouver une
satisfaction profonde à défendre un tel
texte
le meilleur possible à mon avis sur un
tel sujet personne n'a jamais contestée
et le ministre de la santé moins que
quiconque que l'avortement soit un échec
quand il n'est pas un drame mais nous ne
pouvons plus fermer les yeux sur les 300
milles avortement qui chaque année
mutilent les femmes de ce pays qui
bafoue la loi et qui humilie ou
traumatise dell qui ont recours
l'histoire nous montre que les grands
débats qui ont divisé un moment les
français apparaissent avec le recul du
temps comme une étape nécessaire à la
consommation d'un nouveau consensus
social qui s'inscrit dans la tradition
de tolérance et de mesure de notre pays
je ne suis pas de ceux et de celles qui
craignent l'avenir les jeunes
générations nous surprennent parfois ans
qu'elle diffère de nous nous les avons
nous-mêmes élevé de façon différente de
celle dont nous l'avons été mais cette
jeunesse et courageuse capable
d'enthousiasmer de sacrifices comme les
autres sachant lui faire confiance pour
conserver à la vie sa valeur suprême
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]